bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
ce matin l'examen en première lecture
d'une proposition de loi de l'Assemblée
nationale tendant au développement à
l'encadrement des stages et à
l'amélioration du statut des
stagiaire cette proposition de loi vise
à réaffirmer que le stage doit être un
outil à part par entière au service de
la formation et d'autre part à mieux
protéger les droits des stagiaires alors
le nombre des stagiaires a fortement
augmenté ces dernières années de 600000
en 2006 ils sont passés à 1006 en 2012
par ailleurs certaines entreprises
recourent parfois abusivement à des
stagiaires en substitution des salariés
ce texte vise donc à réaffirmer que le
stage est un outil de formation et et
non une fin en sohait il a été voté hier
soir par le Sénat et la proposition de
loi prévoit donc de renforcer la durée
des stages à 6 mois de limiter le nombre
des stagiaires au sein des entreprises
et d'exonérer l'impôt sur le revenu les
gratifications versé au stagiaires
gratifications qui ont été augmenté par
un amendement des
sénateurs madame procaen vous nous
présentez le 137 rectifié bis
oui je je vous conseille éventuellement
d'aller sur le site de n'importe quelle
entreprise et de chercher emploi et à la
rubrique Emploi bah vous découvrirez que
la plupart du temps ce ne sont pas des
emplois qui sont proposés mais ce sont
des stages
or stage et emploi stage CDD stage et
apprentissage c'est pas la même chose
donc l'objectif de cet amandement est
très simple et ne devrait pas être très
compliqué mais c'est d'obliger les
entreprises sur leur site internet
dans la rubrique
Emploi de créer des des sous-rubriques
en mettant une sous-rubrique stage pour
ne pas laisser croire qu'il y a 50
emplois et quand on clique sur chacun
des emplois on se rend compte que ce
sont des
stages bien monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur C amendement cet
amendement 137 oui l'amendement de
Madame procacia vise à encadrer la
diffusion d'offres de stage sur internet
pour éviter la confusion avec des offres
d'emploi donc nous avons une longue
discussion sur ce sujet en commission et
donc je partage et la commission partage
l'objectif qui est celui de Madame
cocacia nous avons travaillé ensemble à
une nouvelle rédaction de l'amendement
c'est la rédaction qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui et qui est celle donc qui me
semble répondre à la nécessité de mettre
un terme à la confusion trop souvent
entretenu entre offre de stage et
d'emploi par certains recruteurs donc
avec cette rectification la commission a
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption de
cet amendement la ministre quel est l'AV
du gouvernement oui monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
procass le gouvernement n'est pas sûr
que ce soit du niveau de la loi mais
comme l'intention est bonne j'en appelle
à la sagesse de l'Assemblée je mets au
vo le 137 rectifi bis qui est pour qui
est contre qui s'abstient l'amendement
est adopté et le 28 est présenté par
Madame
pasasquet
monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez je vais défendre qu
amendements en même temps le 2 je
permets très bien je m'en doutis un peu
le 28 29 30 et
31 puisqu'ils ont tous en commun de
porter sur les conditions les modalités
de cisine des conseils de prudom par les
stagiaire la proposition de loi abord
aborde dans sa rédaction actuelle la
question voyant à la suite de l'adoption
d'un amendement de nos amis du groupe
GDR qu'en cas de saisi le conseil de
prudomme statut immédiatement conseil
cela pour effet d'accélérer la procédure
et c'est tant mieux contte tenu de la
situation particulièrement difficile
dans laquelle se trouent les stagiaires
contraints de saisir les prudommes pour
autant il nous semble que le dispositif
peut-être complété et c'est précisément
le sens de nos
amendements en effet les conditions de
saisine des conseils prudum reste
d'abord et avant tout jurisprudentielle
notamment pour obtenir la
requalification d'un stage dans un
contrat de travail une construction
jurisprudentielle que nous regrettons
puisque par le passé avant la
recodification du Code du travail il
existait un article dans la partie
réglementaire précisant les cas où les
conditions permettant au stagiaire
d'agir en justice dès lors afin de
faciliter les démarches des stagiaires
dans la reconnaissance de leurs droits
nous proposons de préciser explicitement
que le stagiaire peut saisir les juges
prudomo dès lors qu'il estime que
l'organisation d'accueil n'a pas
respecté ses obligations figurant le que
l'organisme d'accueil n'a pas respecté
ses obligations figurant dans la
convention de stage qui plusé nous
proposons d'apporter à la rédaction
actuelle deux précisions l'une portant
sur lesffets de la requalification dont
nous souhaitons préciser que ces effets
débutent dès le premier jour et l'autre
précisant que la prescription d'action
du stagiaire est enfermée dans un délai
de 3 ans c'est-à-dire un an de plus que
le délai de prescription en droit
commun enfin notre dernier amendement
porte sur les effets de la
requalification et d'une manière plus
globale sur la réparation que pourra
décider le conseil de prudom nous
proposons de préciser dans la loi que
lorsque le conseil de prudom fait droit
à la demand du stagiaire il peut lui
accorder le salaire normalement dû pour
le poste occupé le paiement des heures
supplémentaires accompes en
méconnaissance de la convention de stage
ainsi que le paiement de l'indemnité lié
au paiement des congéss des congéss
payés afférant au postees occupés par le
stagiaire merci chers collègu quel est
euh votre avis monsieur le rapporteur
avis de la commission sur le 28 sur le
28 alors sur le 28 de Madame Cohen qui t
à permettre la saisite du conseil de
prudum pour une requalification si le
stagiaire estime que l'organisme
d'accueil n'a pas respé ses obligations
figurant dans la convention de stage
alors la realification d'une convention
de stage en contrat de travail repose
bien sur le fait que les activités
exercées en réalité par le stagiaire ne
correspondent pas à celles prévu par la
Convention dans des conditions qui ne
sont pas traditionnellement celles
réservées à des stagiaires de plus c'est
bien le stagiaire qui est à l'origine de
la demande de requalification cet
amendement me semble donc pleinement
satisfait par l'état actuel du droit en
particulier par la jurisprudence de la
Cour de cassation c'est pourquoi la
Commission demande le retrait sinon
c'est un avis
défavorable madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement même avis pour
les mêmes motifs monsieur le
Président bien madame Pasquet je je mets
au voix
oui bien je mets au moi le 28 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté madame procaa
c'est vous qui présentez le 97
oui tout comme lorsqu'on avait parlé de
l'apprentissage on estimait que le
premier
contact avec lors d'un conflit ne devait
pas être devant les prudommes là on
estime aussi que lorsqu'il y a un
problème de requalification du contrat
de travail à ça soit
porté avant de passer directement devant
les prudesommes ça serait mieux qu'il y
ait une phase de conciliation débute
enfin c'est déjà pas une carrière
professionnelle mais si le premier
contact avec l'entreprise se traduit
déjà par aller devant les tribunaux je
pense que le jeune aura une vision sans
doute assez négatif du monde du travail
et c'est pas l'objectif du
stage bien quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président donc
l'amendement de Madame procia prévoit le
passage le bureau conciliation du
Conseil des prudum en cas de demande de
requalification du contrat la convention
de stage au contrat de travail la
procédure spécifique prévue pour la
requalification qui reprend celle qui
existe en cas de demande de
requalification d' CDD en CDI vise à
permettre un traitement rapide de la
demande cet objectif est incompatible
avec le passage devant le bureau de
conciliation dont on sait la durée pour
tout un tas de raisons que je n'ai pas
aborder ici mais qui sont qui ne sont
pas neutres hein et donc afin de prévoir
un examen dans un délai d'un mois par le
bureau de jugement je pense qu'il faut
maintenir le texte tel qu'il est rédigé
c'est donc un avis
défavorable madame la ministre
oui même avis pour les mêmes motifs
monsieur le Président bien je mets donc
au voix le 97 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté le 99
n'est pas défendu et ensuite dans les
deux amendements en discussion commune
j'ai le 132 qui n'est pas défendu de
Madame linman Jean vient donc au 29
puis-je qui a été présenté puis-je
considérer qu'il y a le même avis de la
commission et du gouvernement que pour
le 28 et par conséquent le même vote
vous êtes d'accord bien donc
l'amendement n'est pas adopté le 30 même
chose puisqu'il s'agit de c'est comme
pour le
28 non vous avez un autre avis monsieur
le
bon donc conséquence de requalification
de la convention de stageat de travail
donc cet amendement précise que les
prudommes pourront accorder au
stagiaires les sommes et indemnités heur
supplémenta qu' j'ai payé normalement du
à l' salarié pour le PO de travail
occupé il s'agit de la jurisprudence
constante de la Cour de cassation qui
est d'ailleurs plus étendue puisqu'elle
intégre également les indemnités de
rupture de contrat donc il ne faut pas
que cette liste puisse apparaître
limitative donc l'amendement à mon sens
est satisfait pourrait être
contreproductif donc nous invitons les
auteurs à le retirer oou c'est un amis
défavorable bien madame la ministre même
avis même raison et pour le le donc je
le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté le 31 qui est déjà été défendu
même même
avis défavorable du rapporteur et du
gouvernement et même vote donc il n'est
pas
adopté et enfin nous en arrivons à deux
amendements en discussion commune euh
donc il est seul d'ailleurs puisque
madame linman n'est pas là le 32 c'est
Madame CEN oui merci monsieur le
Président la loi Hôpital Patient Santé
territoire a placé les établ les
étudiants des établissements médicaux et
paramédicaux sociaux dans une situation
injuste puisque ces derniers ne peuvent
pas bénéficier de la gratification des
stages qu'ils réalisent à l'inverse des
étudiants des autres filières et ce
alors même que leurs stages sont
obligatoires pour valider leurs cursus
et que très vite ils accomplissent des
missions et des actes qui sont utiles
aux établissements dans lesquels ils
interviennent cette disposition qui
s'apparente à une véritable rupture
d'égalité entre étudiants en fonction de
la formation qu'il poursuivent est in
justuste pour les stagiaires raison pour
laquelle en séance publique madame la
ministre s'était engagé à ce que la
gratification des stagiaires des
fonctions publiques territoriales et
hospitalières prévu depuis la loi
enseignement supérieur recherche de juin
2013 s'applique à la rentrée 2014 c'est
pourquoi comme nous l'avions proposé
lors de l'examen de la loi HPST à
l'image d'ailleurs de nos collègues du
groupe socialiste à l'époque nous
proposons de supprimer la dernière
phrase de l'article L
4381-1 du code de la santé publique et
le 2è alinéa de l'article L
612-11 du code de l'éducation de telle
sorte que tous les stagiaires y compris
les infirmiers les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes ou encore les
ergothérapeutes puissent bénéficier
d'une gratification je vous remercie
bien monsieur Goro quel est l'avis de la
commission oui sur ce sur cette
proposition il s'agit donc de
l'existence de ce régime dérogatoire je
le dis très clairement ne me réjouis pas
vraiment mais il est
nécessaire au vu de l'organisation des
formations de ces professions le
remettre en cause aujourd'hui serait la
cause de très importantes difficultés
donc j'espère toutefois que le
gouvernement engagera une réflexion mais
en l'état actuel des choses c'est un
avis défavorable madame la ministre quel
est l'avis du Gouvernement oui monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice je je
confirme cette avis défavorable parce
que la mise en place d'une telle
gratification c'est la raison pour
laquelle en lisant que le ministère de
la Santé nous avons exclu du nous avions
exclu du champ de la loi du 22 juillet
2013 les auxiliaires médicaux euh une
telle gratification
représenterait un montant de près de 600
millions d'euros et à la charge
principale des établissements de soins
donc on voit bien la difficulté par
ailleurs il convient de de souligner que
les étudiants paramédicaux peuvent
bénéficier de l' isation de contraintes
qui à l'accomplissement de de leur stage
c'est l'article
l4381-1 du code de la santé publique et
que certains d'entre eux perçoivent des
indemnités de stage versé par
l'établissement de santé support au
gestionnaire je donne quelques exemples
infirmier première année 230 € pour 10
semaines de stage ergothérapeute 2e
année 360 € pour 12 semaines de stage
maassœur kinésithérapeute 3e année 800 €
pour 20 semaines de stage donc c'est
vrai que ça n'est pas globalement
satisfaisant mais en l'état actuel
du du contexte budgétaire que
connaissent les établissements de soins
nous mettrions gravement en danger leur
équilibre financier en remettant les
auxiliaires médicaux dans le droit
général des des gratifications de stage
donc pour ces raisons je propose un avis
défavorable monsieur desessar a la
parole pour explication de
vote et je vais voter l'amendement
numéro 32 j'ai du mal à
comprendre le raisonnement sinon que
l'État est à part moi depuis le début de
de cette proposition de de loi j'entends
parler qu'il faut unifier cohérence
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai retiré
à un moment malgré forte réticence un
amendement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
j'ai j'ai adopté beaucoup de
propositions du gouvernement et du
rapporteur parce que c'était cette
cohérence on
considère que le stagiaire n'est pas
salarié n'est pas un demialarié c'est
pas le premier pas pour l'emploi c'est
un période importante dans la formation
et on a dit il y a deux attitudes la
première attitude serait de différencier
suivant les cas de Figur parce qu'on
sait très bien que c'est pas la même
chose on demande pas la même chose à
quelqu'un dans le secondaire et
quelqu'un qui a TR ou 4 années de
formation on a dit on unifie il y a eu
des demandes puisque il y a des gens qui
ont dit dans certains centre dans
certaines associations médicales
associativ ça vaê difficile il y a pas
de moyen on a dit on maintient la
cohérence partout on maintient la
cohérence et là
hop brusquement d'un seul coup le
rapporteur le gouvernement dit non c'est
pas possible alors vous vous dites parce
que ça vaut de là ça coûte mais aussi ça
coûtait avant à d'autres lorsque c'est
des associations toute façon c'est soit
des municipalités soit des départements
soit l'état ça coûte on a pris une
cohérence on essaie de s'y tenir depuis
un certain temps puisque on débat depuis
assez longtemps de ce débat enfin de de
ce de cette proposition de loi on fait
une cohérence et d'un seul coup l'état
dit non non pas nous non non vraiment là
ça va pas non non non non nous on n pas
concerné on vous demande à tout le monde
attention faut que ça soit la même chose
mais nous non ça va coûter de l'argent
mais ça coûte à tous pu alors moi j'ai
entendu le gouvernement parler des bas
salaires parler des difficultés
financières de relancer le pouvoir
d'achat c'était l'occasion d'unifier
c'était l'occasion pour tout le monde
évidemment lorsqu'il y a des
investissements à un certain moment il y
a un retour j'ai cru comprendre qu'on en
parlait comme cela pour les entreprises
on investit fortement pour les
entreprises à coût de milliards et on
aura des retombées positives la c'était
simple tout ce que vous nous avez dit ça
veut dire ils sont déjà indemnisé là et
indisé là donc la somme totaleerait pas
tellement importante et cet argent qui
serait investi pour avoir la cohérence
d'une proposition de loi et bien elle
servirait aux artisans aux commerçant et
à l'ensemble de la population puisque ce
sont quand même pas les stagiaires qui
vont investir à l'extérieur des
frontières ça serait directement
consommé sur place donc ça veut dire ça
participe à la vie économique locale
donc là je ne comprends absolument pas
la cohérence du rapporteur et absolument
pas la cohérence du gouvernement depuis
le début on a dit on adopte la même
chose le même raisonnement et là d'un
seul coup alors maintenant ça veut dire
que ça détruit tout on se sent un peu
floué on on on lance à chaque fois on
dit non pas de cas particulier c'est
l'intérêt de proposition de loi et là
d'un seul coup on met en place une autre
cohérence c'est très difficile à
comprendre bien je j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe CRC sur cet amendement numéro 32
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable l'avis du
Gouvernement également il va donc être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement et le scrutin sera donc ouvert
dans quelques
instants
bien le scrutin est
ouvert
c'est bien
ça
plus personne ne demande à voter bien le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
alors résultat du scrutin numéro 181 sur
l'amendement numéro 32
nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
346 pour l'adoption 31 contre 315 le
Sénat n'a pas
adopté nous en venons à deux amendements
en discussion commune le premier est
l'amendement numéro 10 qui va être
présenté par Monsieur des
cessar monsieur des cessar il est
défendu votre amendement numéro 10
monsieur des
cessard
10 laosition de loi prévoit le
renforcement des pouvoirs de
l'inspection du travail pour s'assurer
du respect des conditions de travail des
stagiaires ces dispositions vont
évidemment dans le bon sens
mais il convient également de renforcer
le contrôle en interne dans
l'entreprise c'est pourquoi par cet
amendement nous proposons que les
instances représentatives du personnel
soient informé de manière trimestrielle
sur nombre de stagiaires présents dans
l'entreprise cet amendement leur
permettra de jouer pleinement jouer leur
rôle en assurant de matière plus étroite
la défense des intérêts des stagiaires
c'est quand même plus facile de vérifier
les conditions d'accueil de stage
lorsqu'on est dans l'entreprise que
lorsqueon nous sommes à l'extérieur
cette disposition est issue de l'accord
national interprofessionnel du 7 juin
2011 sur l'accès des jeunes au stage et
à l'alternance elle fait ainsi l'objet
d'un large consensus parmi les
organisations syndicales et patronales
lors des négociations le
mdeef bon je sais là je vais pas me
faire que des amis lorsque je dis ça
mais ne s'était d'ailleurs pas opposé à
cette
mesure c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui cet amendement
afin d'enrichir le dispositif de cette
proposition de loi et permettre au
représentant du personnel d'être informé
des flux et des conditions d'accueil des
stagiaires bien et l'amendement 36
rectifié de Madame est défendu par
Madame Pasquet oui merci monsieur le
Président dans ce rapport notre collègue
Jean-Pierre gaefroid fait référence à
Laan du 7 juin 2011 sur le dév ement des
de l'alternance de l'encadrement des
stages en rappelant que celui-ci a été à
l'origine de mesures positives et que
fait notable il avait été signé par
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et patronales toutefois malgré cette
unanise rare cette transposition n'a été
que partielle et certaines dispositions
pourtant contenues dans l'accord ne se
sont n'ont jamais vu n'ont
jamais
non n' pas vu le jour dans un projet de
loi c'est le cas de la disposition qui
fait l'objet de cet amendement et qui
prévoit que le comité d'entreprise ou à
défaut les délégués du personnel soient
informé une fois par trimestre du nombre
de stagiaires accueillis dans
l'entreprise et de leurs
caractéristiques ainsi que le cas
échéant des causes éventuelles de
rupture de stage cette disposition est
déjà ayant déjà fait l'objet d'un accord
unanime des partenaires sociaux nous
espérons qu'il en sera de même pour C C
amendement monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur ces deux
amendements peut-être décevoir madame
Cohen mais bon alors c'est valable pour
les deux pour les deux amendementsin
donc cet amendement nous semble
satisfait par les dispositions de
l'article L 2323-51 du Code du travail
qui prévoit que chaque trimestre dans
les entreprises d'au moins 300 salariés
l'employeur informe le comité
d'entreprise du nombre de stagiaires
accueillis dans l'entreprise des
conditions de leur accueil et des tâches
qui leur sont confié dans les
entreprises de plus petite taille c'est
le rapport sur la situation économique
de l'entreprise qui contient ces
informations c'est l'article L 22- 47
donc j'invite les auteurs à retirer leur
amendement sinon c'est un avis
défavorable du gouvernement madame la
ministre
oui même avis monsieur le le président
parce que en réalité ces dispositions
sont
satisfaites bien je mets donc au voit
l'amendement numéro 10 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté et le 36
rectifié qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté non plus
je vais donc mettre au voie l'article
1er tel qu'il a pu être amendé qui est
pour
madame procacia auparavant pour une
explication de
vote je dirais que nous avons passé de
soirées sur cet article 1 parce que
c'est un article quand même
particulièrement important il y a dans
cet article 1 reformuler un certain
nombre de bonnes choses et en tout cas
pour ma part j'insisterai surtout sur
quelque chose qui me paraît nouveau et
j'espère qu'il se réalisera c'est
l'implication des état blissement
d'enseignement supérieur parce que un
gros problème des gros problèmes que
rencontrent les stagiaires ne viennent
pas simplement des entreprises ils
viennent des établissements
d'enseignement quel qu'il soit supérieur
ou autre qui envoi leurs élèves ou leurs
étudiants dans des stages sans se
préoccuper par la suite du contenu du
stage sans avoir ce
suivi que l'on a réussi à faire voter
par
amendement donc c'est quelque chose deès
très important par contre malgré un
certain nombre d'éléments comme le
nombre maximal de stagiair ou par
entreprise qui sera fixé par descès et
qui nous laisse nous législateurs quand
même dans énormément de flou euh pour ma
part je malgré les avancées sur les
maisons familiales et rurales pour ma
part je m'abstiendrai et je pense que le
groupe UMP s'abstiendra sur cet article
1 parce que je continue a trouvver
étrange que dans un texte on nous
demande simplement d'autoriser de faire
des choses par décret alors ça sert à
quoi que l'on soit là mais en tout cas
sur sur l'encadrement et l'encadrement
des
stagiaires je demeure intimement
persuadé que ça va faire peur un bon
nombre d'entreprises et que ça
va diminuer peut-être l'offre de
stage monsieur Desessard pour
explication
doote il y avait
euh deux possibilités d'aborder le
problème
des de de du problème des des stages et
des abus de stagiaires soit on faisait
un projet de loi général avec des
applications secteur par
secteur en fonction du niveau de
formation c'est-à-dire un peu à la carte
pour tenir compte de qu'on appelait la
réalité du terrain on va dire c'était la
position plutôt défendue par l'UMP et
l'UDI et puis il y avait une autre
cohérence avec des différences dans le
curseur qui était la position de la
gauche et des écologistes de dire et
bien on essaie d'avoir une cohérence
globale pour l'ensemble des stages de
façon que il y ait un des
principes donc on a plutôt choisi cette
voie làà on aurait pu choisir l'autre
hein dis franchement je ne suis pas du
tout sûr que ça puisse se réaliser dans
tous les secteurs mais en tout cas on a
choisi ça nécessite des moyens ça
nécessite une mise en œuvre on a fait ce
Paris nous y sommes allés donc on va
continuer on va voter pour nous les
écologistes C article 1er mais on est
très quand même
déçu par le refus de d'adopter l'article
30 enfin l'amendement 32 présenté par le
groupe CRC qui permettait justement
cette unification cette cohérence
globale et donc là c'est à ne plus rien
y comprendre on fonce on y va on est
prêt à la stratégie on la suit c'est ça
qui nous cimente et à un moment donné on
dit ah non on joue plus là c'est plus
possible on y va plus mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces stratégies qu'on qu'on
n'assume pas entièrement qu'est-ce que
c'est que ces stratégies où on décide
pas d'aller jusqu'au bout pour voir les
résultats si on commence effectivement
et vous l'avez dit madame la ministre à
miter le projet c'est à considérer que
dans certains endroits il faut faire
autrement mais pourquoi pas les
dérogations dans les mois qui viennent
non on va voter parce qu'on est dans
cette stratégie on va voter pour mais
malgré tout avec une déception que cette
stratégie ne soi pas cohérente et
assumer jusqu'au
bout bien donc
oui monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur
le Président c'est je je je vais
m'exprimis non pas en tant que
rapporteur mais à titre personnel
quelques instants bien évidemment
l'article 1er je le voterai il y a pas
de souci parce que je considère que le
texte qui vient de l'Assemblée et le
travail que nous faisons ici est tout à
fait productif je voudrais
réétirer mon mon
regret du vote de l'amendement de
Monsieur barbier qui revient sur les
dispositions que nous avion prises
concernant la durée du stage à 35 he
c'estàdire durée légale du travail j'y
reviendrai pas par contre madame la
ministre je je continue être vigilant et
je n'exclus pas de voir en Commission
permanente si on peut faire quelque
chose car je ne suis pas convaincu je ne
suis pas convaincu je ne suis pas
convaincu que nous avons pris un
amendement adopt un amendement madame
procassia pour faire en sorte que les
employeurs ne puissent pas diminuer la
gratification quand il y a des ponts ce
que nous avions vérifié dans un certain
nombre de de sociétés je pense que je
souhaite que l'on puisse vérifier à
partir de là que la gratification quand
la durée du temps de travail dépasse les
35 he et bien augmenté à du proportion
du temps de travail dépassé des 35 he
donc pour l'instant je n'ai pas je je ne
dis pas que c'est que c'est pas possible
j'ai j'ai un doute je reste dans le
doute et je pense qu'il faut que ce
doute soit levé parce que c'est au moins
un minima que dans la mesure où
l'amendement de Monsieur Barbier a été
adopté et que maintenant le temps de
travail peut-être porté à plus d'heures
que les 35 he réglementaires que la
gratification suiv en même temps le même
mouvement je vous remercie monsieur le
Président bien
euh je vais donc mettre au voix le vote
au vote cet article 1er ainsi
rectifié amendé pardon qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient donc l'article 1er
est adopté euh à ce stade je
souhaiterais vous rappeler que
normalement on arrête à minuit et demi
he et que comme vous avez pu le
voir si nous n'avons pas terminé nous
reprendrons dans les semaines suivantes
comme ains que la voilà et oui on peut
arriver à terminer à condition que
chacun y mette un peu du sien moi je n'y
vois pas de
d'inconvénient bien alors après
l'article
1er j'ai un amendement numéro qui est
présenté par Monsieur
dessa par cet amendement nous souhaitons
confier à l'Observatoire de la vie
étudiante une mission de statistiqu et
d'études sur les stages aujourd'hui
notre pays manque cruellement de données
fiables sur les stagiaires pour éclairer
l'action publique dans ce domaine cela a
été dit à plusieurs reprises mais nous
ne pouvons estimer précisément
aujourd'hui le nombre de stagiaires en
France nos estimation varie de 1,6
million à 2 million de personnes ce qui
représente une marge d'erreur de 20 %.
pour connaître plus précisément les
conditions de vie d'étude de travail des
stagiaires il convient qu'un organisme
puisse nous livrer des statistiques
fiables l'Observatoire de la vie
étudiante qui s'est spécialisé dans
l'étude du monde étudiant pourrait se
chargé de ces missions puisque ses
attributions actuels sont connexes il
conviendra bien entendu de doter cette
structure de plus de personnel l'article
40 nous empêchant d'alourdir les charges
publiques je vous demande madame la
ministre de nous aider à y médier bien
monsieur le rapporteur quel est votre
avis favorable de la commission madame
la
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le le sénateur le gouvernement aura une
position un peu différente de celle du
rapporteur parce que nous considérons
que un travail est en cours l' ve est
déjà tout à fait habilité à produire des
études sur les stagiaires puisque les
stagiaires sont des étudiants quand les
stagiaires sont des étudiants des
éléments quantifiés sont déjà produits
et cont contribu à la production de
l'enquête statistique réalisée chaque
année par les services de la DG CIP donc
les services de la Direction Générale
d'enseignement supérieur et de
l'insertion professionnel mais il reste
limité aux seuls universités aux
établissements qui dépendent directement
du du ministère conscient qu'il est
nécessaire de développer les
statistiques sur les stages le
gouvernement s'est engagé dans une
réflexion sur ce thème avec notamment
les services de l'INC des réunions de
travail ont déjà été conduites cette
année et vont se poursuivre pour définir
un mode de recueil statistique plus
pertinent et péren au niveau national
ainsi nous pourrons assurer un meilleur
suivi des stages et des stagiaires mais
pour le pour le moment pardon il semble
toutefois sans objet d'indiquer dans la
loi une mission particulière vis-à-vis
des étudiants lesqueles sont déjà une
cible d'étude pour l'Observatoire de la
vie étudiante c'est pourquoi je m'en
remets à votre sagesse pour éviter comme
vous l'avez dit vous-même d'alourdir un
texte et je vous propose de de retirer
cet amendement en sachant que je partage
votre préoccupation et que les
différences chiffré que vous
peuvent s'expliquer mais je veux pas
allonger le temps d'intervention et je
vous expliquerai à quoi elles sont des
c'est
ça nai pas dit que j'alourdissais le
texte puisque simplement je demande dans
mon amendement de rajouter a des
stagiaires donc c'est quand même pas
alourdir le test que de demander que et
des stagiaires ça veut dire qu'on pointe
particulièrement que ce ne sont pas
simplement les les statistiques sur les
étudiants mais qu'on fait attention
aussi au stages et au stagiaires et vous
avez dit madame la ministre que vous
comptez le faire donc il s'agit de
rajouter le mot et des stagiaires bon
voilà donc après après j'ai dit que ça
pouvait alourdir le budget puisqu'on va
demander à s'occuper des stagiaires mais
madame la ministre vous m'avez dit il le
fait déjà donc c'est là que je il y a
pas de frais supplémentair puisquil le
fait déjà on pointe simplement par mon
amendement en mettant le mot et des
stagiaires que il faut pas oublier la
dimension de formation dans les
entreprises donc je mets au voix cette
amendement numéro 7 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient est
adopté
après l'article
1er je
suis saisi d'un amendement 34 34
présenté par Madame Pasquet non madame
pardon excusez-moi non mais j'ai je joue
au qure coins je joue au qure coins
c'est pour ça comme vous le savez la
rédaction de l'article L 1221-2 du Code
du travail prévoit qu'une entreprise
embauche un stagiaire à la fin de son
stage
alors la durée du stage est déduite de
la période d'cès toutefois il ne s'agit
que d'une déduction partielle puisque
cette réduction ne s'opère que dans la
limite de 50 % de la durée prévue au
départ ainsi le stagiaire est embauché à
la fin d'un stage qui a duré 4 mois et
dont le contrat prévoit une période
d'cès de 2 mois ne doit plus réaliser
une période décès que d'un mois c'est
tout à fait positif pour autant il nous
semble qu'il est possible de prévoir que
dès lors que le recrutement en CDI fait
suite à un stage réussi par définition
la durée du stage doit être
intégralement déduite de la période
d'essès et non pas pour moitié cela nous
paraît d'autant plus opportun que ces
périodes d'essès peuvent atteindre 3
mois pour un agent de maîtrise et 4 mois
pour le recrutement d'un cadre or si
l'employeur décide de recruter un ancien
stagiaire c'est qu'il a déjà la
certitude que cet ancien stagiaire
devenu nouveau salarié détient les
compétences requises à la réussite du
poste qu'il s'est vu attribuer cela
participe d'un mouvement sécurisation
d'entrée dans la vie professionnelle
sans constituer pour autant une
contrainte de taille à la charge des
employeurs c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons que notre amendement soit
adoptéteur avis de la commission
oui monsieur le Président le régime
actuel résulte d'un accord national
interprofessionnel de 2011 signé à
l'unanimité par les partenaires sociaux
de plus le stage est déjà déduit
intégralement de la période d'cès
lorsque l'emploi en question est en
correspondance avec les activités qui
avaient ét est confié au stagiaire il
s'agit d'après moi du cas de figure le
plus majoritaire le stage constituant
une forme de prérecrutement pour un
poste précis il me semble qu'il faut sur
ce point respecter la volonté des
partenaires sociaux donc c'est une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable madame la ministre même avis
même motif monsieur le Président
bien donc je mets au voix je mets au
voix l'amendement 34 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n pas
adopté à l'article
2 un amendement de Marseille qui
tombe un amendement de Monsieur Charles
Revet donc le 63 rectifié bis en
discussion commune oui merci monsieur le
Président la loi 201440 du 20 janvier
2014 garantissant l'avenir et la justice
du système de retraite a prévu que les
étudiants ayant effect un stage éligible
à une gratification donc d'une durée
supérieure à 2 mois pourront valider
celui-ci pour le retraite pour assurer
la traçabilité de ces stages
l'inscription des stagiaires sur le
registre du personnel de l'organisme
d'accueil apparaît parfaitement
cohérente étendre cette formalité à tous
les stages apparî disproportionnés voire
dissuasive pour les organismes d'accueil
imagine-on un artisan ou un agriculteur
ouvrir un registre du personnel pour un
stage de 15 jours par exemple il est
donc proposé d'en rester à une
obligation qui ne concernerait que les
stages éligibles à une gratification
pour les raisons exposées si
dessus
bien l'amendement de Madame linman tombe
madame Cohen non madame pascet
l'amendement
35 merci monsieur le
Président depuis 2008 les entreprises
doivent disposer d'une liste des
conventions de stage qu'elles conclu
ce document a pris la forme avec la loi
charpion du 28 juillet 2011 d'un
registre des conventions de stage qui
est toutefois distinct
euh du registre unique du personnel qui
pour mémoire les noms prénom de tous les
salariés de l'établissement dans l'ordre
des embauches ainsi qu'une liste
d'indications complémentaires dans
l'emploi ou la
qualification les députés ont souhaité
par souci de simplification la
disparition de ce registre des
conventions et faire figurer dans une
partie spécifique du registre unique du
personnel les noms et prénoms des
stagiaires accueillis dans l'organisme
signataire nous souscrivons pleinement à
cette mesure et dans la continuité de
cette disposition il nous semble que le
registre unique du personnel devrait
également indiquer la durée du stage et
l'émission confié au stagiaires cette
précision nous a paraît utile afin de
permettre aux représentants du personnel
de disposer de tous les éléments qui
leur semblent utiles et de faciliter les
les démarche des agents de contrôle de
l'inspection du travail et des ursaves
qui ont accès à ce
document
bien monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces deux amendements sur
l'amendement sur l'amendement de
Monsieur revet donc demande
d'inscription des stagiaire et donc pour
ceux issus de l'enseignement supérieur
l'intérêt d'inscrire les stagiaires dans
le registre unique du personnel et
d'assurer le leur suivi dans l'organisme
d'accueil par tous ceux délégués du
personnel insspecteur du travail qui ont
taxé ce n'est pas une formalité
surmontable donc c'est un avis
défavorable et l'amendement de Madame
Cohen je je demanderai le retrait parce
que ce sont des mesures qui à mon sens
relèvent du pouvoir réglementaire
puisqu'il s'agit d'inscrire la durée du
stage et les mississions confié au
stagiaires madame la ministre quel est
votre avis sur ces de amendements même
avis pour les mêmes raisons monsieur le
Président bien je mets donc au voit
l'amendement 63 rectifié bis qui est est
pour qui est
contre il n'est pas
adopté et le
35 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté non plus je mets donc au voit
l'article 2 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 2 est adopté après l'article 2
che nous en sommes à l'amendement 37
présenté par Madame Cohen oui monsieur
le Président mes chers collègues vous le
savez les organisations syndicales de
salariés celles représentant les
étudiants et le collective génération
précaire que notre rapporteur a
d'ailleurs auditionné propose que les
stagiaires soient pris en compte dans
l'effectif des entreprises à du
proportion de leur temps de présence
dans cette entreprise cela nous apparît
être une mesure tout à fait
souhaitable afin de lutter contre une
forme d'abus qui consisterait pour
certains employeurs à recruter de
manière plus ou moins permanente des
stagiaires de telle sorte que T à tour
ils correspondent à des postes
permanents tout en évitant que
l'effectif administratif de l'entreprise
excède certains seuils légaux comme
celui des 50 donc il nous paraît très
important de pouvoir accéder à ces
demandes et donc de voter cet amendement
monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission oui monsieur le Président je
resterai dans la même logique puisqu'il
s'agit de prendre en compte les
stagiares dans l'effectif de l'organisme
d'accueil l'appartenance à une
entreprise repose sur la signature d'un
contrat de travail elle existance d'un
lien de subordinisation avec l'employeur
ce n'est pas le cas des stagiaires et il
ne me paraît pas souhaitable de faire
évoluer cette situation donc c'est un
avis défavorable madame la ministre même
avis pour les mêmes raisons on a rappelé
à mentreprise que le stage n'était pas
un contrat de travail ni un emploi et il
y aurait une confusion qui serait amenée
par cet amendement don donc avis
défavorable monsieur le cessard
explication de
vote j'interviens pour expliquer mon
vote puisque je vais pas voter
l'amendement proposé par le CRC mais
j'en suis pas loin alors
une non parce que je reste encore dans
l'idée de ce projet de loi enfin de
cette proposition de loi que le stage
fait partie de la formation alors après
on pourrait on pourrait dire mais à un
autre moment de dire que dans le
registre du personnel on peut noter tous
les flux des stagiaires de toute façon
différente mais là et vous l'avez dit
Madame Cohen vous avez dit c'est la
demande de de Génération précaire et ben
effectivement Génération Précaire eux
ils parlent d'un constat ils disent
beaucoup de stages aujourd'hui sont en
réalité des emplois il faut absolument
lutter contre ça et pour cela il faut
les inscrire dans le registre de
personnel leur donner des droits parce
qu'ils sonttil disait
aujourd'hui nous le groupe écologiste on
a choisi euh la la vision du rapporteur
et donc du gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement a la même optique c'est que
le stage fait partie de la formation
mais Génération Précaire pose un vrai
problème est-ce qu'on pourra longtemps
continuer comme
cela puisque beaucoup de stages sont
utilisés comme premier emploi et eux ils
disent considérons qu'il y a des
vraiment des mes emplois prenons-le en
compte et faisons en sorte qu'ils ont
des conditions décentes et ce à quoi je
je leur ai répondu à à à ceux et à
celles avec qui j'en ai discuté que
c'était rentré dans un contrat premier
embauche c'est-à-dire avec un un revenu
qui serait moindre donc pour cela pour
le moment il est pas question de
légitimer le fait que des stages soient
considérés comme un emploi avec une
gratification inférieur au SMIC donc
voilà pourquoi je ne rentrerai pas comme
le rapporteur l'a indiqué dans cette
logique même si je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup d'abus et je resterai dans la
logique que le stage fait partie de la
formation il n'empêche et je sais que le
gouvernement va considérer que ce n'est
pas le moment d'en parler mais il
n'empêche qu'on pourrait considérer
qu'il pourrait y avoir une allocation
d'étudiants pour tous les étudiants mais
à ce moment-là ce n'est plus la même
chose ce n'est pas l'entreprise qui pie
l'étudiant en stage mais c'est une
allocation d'étudiants pour tous les
étudiants c'est une autre question alors
je sais que vous n'êtes pas d'accord le
MP mais les jeunes socialistes à une
époque étaient d'accord avec une
allocation d'étudiants une adéité pour
étudiant nous y sommes encore favorables
donc il sera toujours temps d'en
discuter dans quelques mois ou dans
quelques temps mais
aujourd'hui j'en resterai dans la
logique du texte c'est-à-dire que que le
stage est un moment de formation
porteur pasonger mais juste un mot je
souscris au propos de Jean deessur mais
l'article 2 répond je pense aux
inquiétudes de de des rédacteurs je
voudrais quand même ass sur un point
c'est que si on introduit le dans le
calcul des effectifs de l'entreprise on
risque se retrouver pour certaines
entreprises avec des effets de seuil
avec toutes les conséquences de l'effet
de seuil donc je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas dans ce texte qu'il faut
ajouter les stagiaires à l'effectif de
l'entre pr le noir pour explication de
vote
monsieur le Président je suis tout à
fait convaincu par les arguments qui ont
été exposés aussi bien par le rapporteur
que Madame la Ministre alors deux choses
d'abord voudrais avoir confirmation que
le stagi apparaît dans le bilan social
des entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
premièrement deuxièmement je ferai quand
même une remarque à notre collègue de
cessar quand il parle d'une
gratification pour les étudiants ça me
rappelle voyons ce qui séit passé en
2006 lorsque un tel dispositif était
proposé par un gouvernement de
l'époque dispositif contre lequel il y
avait une forte mobilisation est-ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment mon cher
collègue que vous rapprochez les
propositions qui avent été faites par un
certain Premier ministre qui s'appelit
monsieur
Villepin
bien
bien je mets donc au voix cet amendement
37 qui est
pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
je mets au voix l'article 3 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient l'article
3 est adopté à l'article
4 j'ai un amendement 149 présenté par le
gouvernement madame la ministre
149 monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'unamendement de cohérence avec
l'amendement de suppression du
gouvernement à l'article le premier euh
l'inspection du travail n'ayant pas pour
mission de contrôler le respect des
stipulations pédagogiques de la
convention de stage il n'y a donc pas
lieu d'étendre sa compétence sur ce
sujet j'en profite pour préciser au
sénateur de cessar que si on inscrit
dans le registre unique du personnel les
stagiaires c'est pour vérifier que le
nombre de stagiaires n'est pas en
excédent par rapport au dispositif
législatif et préciser ensuite par
décret ça ça n'est pas parce que on les
considère comme des membres salariés du
personnel monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur cet
amendement faorable favorable je mets au
voix la l'amendement 149 du gouvernement
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement est adopté et
Madame procassia nous présente le 84
rectifié bis
oui il
s'agit lorsque les étudiants sont
revenus ont fait un rapport de stage où
ont pu dire
effectivement comment c'était déroulé le
stage et et s'ils ont effectué un
travail et non pas un stage en
formation moi je continue à penser que
les stagiaires ne sont pas les plus à
même souvent de pouvoir
contacter l'inspection du travail donc
je suggère d'étendre la possibilité aux
autorité académique compétente de saisir
elle aussi l'inspection du travail si
elle voyait des manquements
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
Président donc il s'agit de prévoir que
l'inspection du travail peut intervenir
sur cesine des autorités académiques
pour contrôler le manquement la
législation bon la question qu'on peut
se poser est-il nécessaire que la loi
précise que l'inspecteur deacadémie
pourra saisir l'inspection du travail
s'il apprend qu'un organisme ne règle
pas ne respecte pas la réglementation
ceci étant comme il nous est très
difficile d' mettre un avis défavorable
sur quelque chose qui nous semble tout à
fait logique mais qui doit se faire nor
normalement donc c'est un avis de un
avis favorable de la commission mais ça
à mon avis ça n'apporte pas grand-chose
madame procacia la situation actuelle
donc je pense que le mieux aurait été de
le retirer en ayant la certitude que ça
fonctionne déjà comme ça et que la
possibilité est déjà offerte à
l'inspection d'académie de saisir
l'inspection du travail s'ils sont
alertés d'un manquement à la
réglementation serait peut-être ça
éviterait peut-être qu'on nous reproche
que la loi est trop bavarde comme nous
le reproche de temps en temps
voilà madame la ministre
oui monsieur le Président comme il est
toujours possible comme ça a été dit
d'ailleurs ça vient d'être raelé par le
rapporteur et même de bonne
administration que les autorités
académiques transmettent les
informations qu' jugent utille à
l'inspection du travail il ne paraît pas
nécessaire au gouvernement que la loi le
prévoit puisqu'on est là dans dans une
redondance et dans l'énoncé du d'une
évidence donc le gouvernement avait émis
un avis
défavorable
bien non dans la mesure où il y a déjà
la possibilité je vais le retirer par
contre j'aimerais bien que vous me
disiez si ça arrive de temps en temps si
vous avez connaissance de l'inspection
du travail saisie une fois par des
autorités bien madame la ministre vous
souhaitez répondre bien sûr monsieur le
Président si vous autorisz oui il y a il
y a des cas effectivement et
les les personnes compétentes du
ministère du Travail me le confirment
l'amendement 84 rectifi bis est donc
retiré et je mets au voix l'article 4
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 4 est adopté à l'article
5 madame procacia toujours oui
s'agit de requalification alors lorsque
le
stagiaire a effectué effectivement une
tâche régulière qui correspond à un
emploi
de salariés permanent sans aller jusqu'à
la realification complète du contrat de
travail on introduit on propose
d'introduire
l'obligation que
l'organisme rémunère au SMIC ou en tout
cas un pourcentage du SMIC qui serait
déterminé par décret mais tout est
déterminé par décret dans ce texte
euh bien monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président donc sur le
principe la Commission et moi-même nous
sommes favorables à cette initiative de
Madame procasscia il faut sanctionner
les employeurs qui ont recours au
stagiair en lieu et place de salariés
permanent toutefois pour qu'une telle
indemnité puisse être versée il faut
qu'elle soit alé par un tribunal qui
aura jugé que la convention de stage
n'était pas conforme à la législation
seul le contentieux de la
requalification de la convention contrat
de travail permet d'y parvenir c'est
donc un amendement d'appel en quelque
sorte qui me semble inabouti en l'état
mais sur sur lequel il faut poursuivre
notre réflexion donc nous avion décidé
de nous en remettre à la sagesse de
notre assemblée sauf àe contraire
peut-être du gouvernement mais ça me
semble madame la ministre quel est donc
l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le Président le le
gouvernement un
avis qu' a concerté avec le ministère du
Travail à ce sujet parce que
l'affectation d'un stagiaire sur un
poste de travail permanent dans
l'entreprise se fait toujours détribment
de de l'embauche d'un salarié ce qui
nous gêne par rapport à la définition
tout de même d'un stagiaire qui est
encore une fois un étudiant ou un élève
en situation de formation et pas non pas
en situation de de
remplacement d'un salarié donc la
requalification c'est les demander et le
juste dédommagement du du stagiaire et
entraîne la sanction nécessaire de
l'infraction ainsi le stagiaire aura
droit au rappel des salaires qui auraiit
dû lui être versé ce salaire ne pvant
être inférieur au SMIC mais également
l'ensemble des droits qui sont associés
au statut du salarié Cong j'ai payé le
cas échéant indemnité de licenciement et
il faut prévoir qu'en cas d'infraction
le stagiaire ne reçoit qu'une indemnité
compensatrice dé terminé en pourcentage
du SMIC je prévoir comme vous comme
comme c'est proposé dans votre
amendement que le stagiaire ne reçoive
qu'une indemnité compensatrice euh en
pourcentage du SMIC irit donc à
l'encontre de l'objectif de cette PPL
qui est de protéger le droit des
stagiaires et de lutter contre le
recours abusif au stage voilà pourquoi
cet amendement nous gêne même s'il est
plein de bonnes intentions mais il va à
l'encontre de la définition même du du
stagiaire
et je je regarde d'ailleurs moiême je
regarde ma formulation parce que c'est
pas dans l'entreprise c'est dans
l'organisme d'accueil quel qu'il soit ça
peut être une administration publique ça
peut être une association ça peut être
une une entreprise donc il faut éviter
de stigmatiser l'entreprise là aussi
c'est l'organisme ou l'entité d'accueil
du
stagiaire bien je mets donc au voix cet
amend
pardon je l'avais compris excusez-moi
bien donc je mets au voix l'amendement
129 rectifié qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté et je mets
au vote l'article 5 qui est pour
l'article
5 qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 5 est
adopté à l'article 6 Monsieur Charles is
oui monsieur le Président je suis un
petit peu ennuyé parce que j'ai une
bonne mémoire mais quand même comme on
travaille plusieurs soirs différent je
sais plus quel sort avait été réservé à
l'abandement 59 et donc comme c'est
s'agissait d'un amendement de
coordination peut-être que monsieur le
rapporteur va pouvoir m'apporter des
précisions comme ça il est c'est
l'amendement 59 a été rejeté et donc
comme c'est un amendement de
coordination c'est évidemment un avis
défavorable monsieur revet monsieur rev
le retire avant que madame la ministre
ne donne son avis d'ailleurs et donc je
mets au voix l'article 6 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient l'article
6 est adopté l'article 7 même vote même
vote il est adopté après l'article
7 j'ai plusieurs amendements en
discussion commune dans le prier 51 sont
des amendements identiques et présenté
par Madame FERR merci monsieur le
Président l'objet de cet amendement est
d'assurer la pérennité et la traçabilité
des financements des gratifications de
stage des travailleurs sociaux en effet
le fond de transition doté de 5,3
million d'euros dont madame la ministre
vous avez annoncé la création paraît
bien insuffisant pour financer les
gratifications des stagiaires dans le
secteur public en 2008 20 millions
d'euros avaient été dégagés pour
financer ces gratifications dans le
secteur associatif faute d'une
ingénierie financière adapté ces crédits
ont été dispersés et se sont dilués dans
les budgets des établissements et
services sociaux et médicos-sociaux pour
résoudre ce problème nous proposons de
créer une enveloppe d'intérêt général
pour les établissements destiné à
financer les stages des élèves ou
étudiants en travail social elle serait
financé par redéploiement de crédit et
par le fond de transit i annoncée ce qui
permettrait de répondre structurellement
à la problématique liée à la
gratification des stagiaires dans le
secteur médico-social en effet les
formations initiales longues et les
formations continues des professionnels
dans les établissements et services
sociaux et médicos-sociaux ont toujours
reposé sur l'alternance entre les
centres de formation et les institutions
ces structur accueillent donc de
nombreux stagiaires sur des périodes
longues qui doivent désormais recevoir
des gratifications financière leur coût
annuel tout financeur confondu a été
évalué en 2008 dans le secteur associ
associatif à 22,3 millions d'euros dont
4,7 à la charge de longdame notre
dispositif permet d'une part d'apporter
un soutien financier aux étudiants et
d'autre part de ne pas pénaliser les
structures d'accueil des stagiaires pour
les établissements d'accueil des jeunes
enfants un envenant à la COG entre la
CAF et l'État devrait permettre de
redéployer les financements nécessaires
à la gratification des stages des
éducateurs de jeunes enfants enfin la
gratification des stagiaires en travail
social devrait être ajouté à l'arrêté
ministériel qui fixe la liste des mijac
dans les établissements de
santé bien
j'ai trois amendements encore identiques
donc le second le 110 rectifié bis est
présenté par Madame
Brugère
rectifier bis amendement identique à
celui que il est défendu il est défendu
il est défendu je vous
remercie monsieur Barbier amendement
identique
également il est défendu je vous
remercie et le 138
rectifié est défendu également il est
défendu également je vous remercie alors
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
alors monsieur le
Président des mesures de soutien ont
déjà été prises par le gouvernement
notamment la mise en place d'un fond de
soutien à la gratification des étudiants
en travail en travail social des Assises
du travail social sont maintenant
attendu pour débattre de l'avenir de ces
métiers cet amendement sous un abord
d'une technicité redoutable crée un
dispositif complexe et rigide qui se
finance par des redéploiements de crédit
dans l'objectif de dépenses médicosocial
le champ exact des organismes visés
n'est pas précisé s'il s'agit uniquement
des établissements et services
médicaux-soaux financé par l'OGD alors
cet amendement est satisfait puisque
depuis 2008 une enveloppe annuelle de
4,7 millions d'euros est alloué pour les
aider à accueillir des
stagiaires en revanche s'il s'agit de
prendre en charge les coûts
qu'entraînent l'accueil de stagiaires
travailleurs sociaux dans les services
propres des conseils généraux ainsi que
dans les établissements et services qui
sont entièrement financés par l'État et
non par l'assurance maladie la solution
proposée n'est pas pertinente en effet
le GD a un champ plus limité que celui
de l'ensemble de ses structures cela
aboutira à priver les épad et les
établissements médicaux-sociaux d'une
partie de leurs ressources et à utiliser
des fonds destinés au financement des
soins à un usage qui ne leur correspond
pas l'assurance maladie n'a pas financé
la formation des travailleurs sociaux
mais bien la prise en charge médicalisé
en épable ou l'établissement ou
établissement pour personnes handicapé
on se trouverait donc dans ce cas un
transfert de charge qui serait
irrçevable au titre de l'article 40 il y
a donc deux cas de Figur soit il s'agit
d'un dispositif qui n'apporte rien et
qui est satisfait soit il est recevable
au titre de l'article irrecevable au
titre de l'article 40 puisque
l'assurance maladie est appelée à
prendre en charge de nouvelles dépenses
qui jusqu'à présent n'était pas de son
rur j'invite donc les auteurs de
l'amendement à préciser leur volonté
mais je pense que dans ces cas-là le
mieux c'est de solliciter l'avis du
Gouvernement euh C c'est l' viis de la
commission me semble que nous avons
résumer la situation et que la BAL est
dans le camp du gouvernement
maintenant madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement sur ces
amendements
identiques monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
ferai une réponse globale puisque la
gratification des des stages au sein des
établissements sociaux et
médicos-sociaux relevant de l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
est applicable depuis 2008 depuis cette
date une enveloppe de 4 million 7 est
fléché annuellement dans la circulaire
de campagne pour le financement de cette
gratification il n'est donc pas juste de
dire qu'il n'existe aucun crédit pour
financer les S les stages dans le
secteur médico-social et que ces crédits
ne seraient pas précisément identifiés
et fléchés ce qui ressort surtout de
l'examen de la consommation de ces
crédits c'est que depuis leur mise en
place ils sont systématiquement
sous-consommés ce n'est donc pas
l'obligation de gratifier les stages qui
explique les difficultés de certains
étudiants à trouver un stage dans C
établissements les difficultés actuelles
rencontré par les étudiants en travail
social pour trouver des stages ne se
situent pas dans le secteur médicau
social associatif dont je que je viens
d'évoquer mais dans les secteurs
nouvellement soumis tels qu'ils ont été
définis par la loi sur dans le casadre
de la loi sur l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche qui était voté le 22
juillet dernier et sont des nouveaux
secteurs qui on est soumis à la
gratification il concerne principalement
les collectivités territoriales puisque
l'État était déjà soumis et le présent
amendement qui ne s'intéresse qu'à la
question des établissements relevant de
l'objectif national de dépense de
l'assurance maladie ne résout pas cette
difficulté nouvelle cette difficulté
nouvelle nous l'avons identifié lors de
la discussion de cette PPL à l'Assemblée
nationale
et euh non d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi
c'est lors de c'est
c'est confusion de ma part c'est lors de
l'examen de la loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche que nous
avions ident
cette difficulté pour les collectivités
territoriales et puis un certain nombre
d'associations dont une que vous
connaissez bien et qui é très active et
très réactive sur le sujet nous avait
fortement alerté nous avons donc négocié
avec le ministère des Affaires social un
fond de transition qui a été créé qui
est destiné à lever les difficultés
temporaires rencontré par les petites
structures notamment les petites
communes ou les petits établissements
publics relevant de la fonction publique
territoriale et nous avons mis en place
pass un fond de de transition de
5ion 300000 € on a fait une évaluation
et on a même fait une évaluation assez
large parce que je pense que
l'expérience va nous montrer que comme
pour le premier fond il ne sera pas
sollicité
dans totalement tout en étant des lieux
de stage je parle des des petites
collectivités particulièrement
intéressant pour les étudiants ils
peuvent être en difficulté en effet pour
financer les gratifications cette année
puisqu'ils n'ont pas pu l'anticiper lors
de la construction de leur budget donc
nous avons mis en place ces dispositions
transitoires qui répondent à toutes les
questions posées par ces amendements et
tout cela s'est fait vraiment en en
concertation avec l'ensemble des
collectivités concerné mais là encore
nous avons voulu étendre au plus grand
nombre des stagiaires les mêmes
dispositifs pour
favoriser l'équité vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des stagiaires même si je
j'anticipe
cette équité n'a pas pu être
complètement globale mais je vois qu'il
n'écoute pas monsieur de César donc
voilà je vous propose un avis
défavorable bien je vais donc mettre au
voix ces
amendements qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient les ces amendements ne sont
pas
adoptés après pardon non
après l'article 7 je suis saisi de trois
amendements
identiques le premier 53 est présenté
par Madame ferra merci monsieur le
Président l'objet de cet amendement est
de permettre aux entreprises qui ne
trouvent pas d'apprentis dans le dans
leur secteur d'activité les services
notamment de ne plus être sanctionné par
le malus que représente le versement de
la contribution supplémentaire à
l'apprentissage pour non respect du
quotat de 4 % d'apprentis euh il il sera
de 5 % 2015 en prenant en compte dans le
calcul de ce quota les stagiaires
embauchés en CDI par l'entreprise à
l'issue de leur stages cette mesure ne
peut qu'inciter les entreprises à
s'impliquer en faveur de l'embauche des
jeunes et de leur formation et ainsi les
aider à s'insérer plus rapidement dans
le monde du
travail amendement 99 identique madame
procacia il est défendu il est défendu
je vous remercie et le 119 rectifié
madame Laborde oui c'est le même
amendement nous l'avions déjà déposé
lors de la discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la formation professionnelle
et il a été défendu par Madame ferra
donc ce sera parfait bien je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces trois amendements
identiques bien monsieur le Président le
C le CSA a pour objet de développer
l'alternance dans les grandes
entreprises
où elle est où elle est bien moins
répandue que dans l'artisanat par
exemple je ne suis pas convaincu qu'on
puisse assimiler un stagiaire
deenseignement supérieur à un apprenti
ou un jeune en contrat de
professionnalisation la politique
publique en faveur du développement de
l'alternance à un objectif clair et la
CSA est l'un de ces outils faut-il y
faire des exceptions au risque d'en
diminuer l'efficacité jeen suis pas
convaincu par ailleurs comment savoir au
moment du stage et du calcul de la CSA
si le stagiaire va être embauché en CDI
ensuite s'il faut que le montant de
cette taxe soit R régularisé
postérieurement cela va créer des
difficultés administratives très
importantes aussi bien pour les
entreprises que pour les services
fiscaux donc pour toutes ces raisons
c'est un avis défavorable aux trois
amendements madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement même avis pour
les mêmes raisons monsieur le
Président bien je vais
donc mettre au voix ces trois
amendements c'est pour le pour ça ou
non 589 oui c'est pour
cel tous les trois bon donc je suis
saisi d' demande de scrutin public sur
ces
amendements demande présentée par le
groupe
UMP je vous rappelle que nous avons un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui doit donc être procédé
au scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement et
le scrutin sera donc ouvert dans
quelques
instants
est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter donc le
scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au au
dépouillement du
scrutin
du scrutin numéro 182 sur les
amendements 53 89 et 119 rectifiés
nombre de votants 346 nombre de suffrage
exprimé
346 pour l'adoption
178 contre 168 le Sénat a
adopté après l'article
7 nous avons amendement 66 rectifier bis
monsieur
revet oui merci monsieur le Président si
si vous en êtes d'accord je vais
présenter en même temps le 66 67 68 et
58 puisqu'ils ont le même sit sont pas
les mêmes les mêmes personnes concernées
c'est le même type d'amendement qui
concerne les aides soignants les
auxiliaires depuis agriculture les
ambulanciers les travailleurs sociaux
les formations comportte des
enseignements magistraux et des temps de
stage professionnels sur leur futur lieu
d'exercice à ce titre les professionnels
susvisés participe à la formation des
élèves et étudiants
soignants dans le cadre de ces cadres
stages pratiques ainsi pour ces
étudiants élèves les stages obligatoires
conditionnent l'accès à la profession et
c'est vrai pour chacune des secteurs que
je indiqué il y a un instant l'accès à
la profession à laquelle il se prépare
et toute difficulté pouvant y faire
obstacle doit être levé c'est pourquoi
le présent amendement vise des sages
liés à un cursus pédagogique intégré à
la formation de ses futurs professionnel
qui ne peuvent de par leur spécificité
bénéficier d'aucune forme de
rémunération de gratification à
l'exclusion des indemnité lié aux
contraintes engendrées par ces stages et
donc les quatre amendements qui sont
différents puisque ça concerne des
personnes différentes mais ont le même
objet c'est pour ça que je les présente
en même temps j'ai bien compris monsieur
monsur revet et je vous remercie euh
monsieur le rapporteur si vous voulez
bien donner votre avis sur les quatre
amendements donc puisqu'ils sont
légèrement différents mais je pense
qu'on peut donner un avis commun sur les
quatre oui monsieur le Président ces
quatre amendements pour obliget
d'exclure de l'obligation de
gratification des stages donc des aides
soignants des auxiliaires de
plriculture de mémire des amb des
ambulanciers et des travailleurs sociaux
donc sur ces quatre amendements ça ne
surprendra pas Monsieur R un avis
défavorable de la
commission madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement même avis pour
les mêmes motifs monsieur le Président
bien
donc je vais mettre au voix
successivement ces quatre amendements
pour le 66 rectifié bis qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté pour le 60 rectifié bis
même vote même vote il n'est pas adopté
non plus le 68 rectifié bis même vote
même vote il n'est pas adopté et le 58
rectifié bis même vote il n'est pas
adopté non plus après l'article 7 j'ai
donc deux amendements en discussion
commune qui sont présentés par Madame
procacia oui tout à fait le gouvernement
a bien annoncé son
intention de se lancer dans l'open data
et un certain nombre d'ailleurs de
ministères euh commence à avoir des
plateformes intéressantes or en matière
de stage il apparaîtrait que si une
plateforme en ligne estitmise ça la
permettrait de donner des informations
concrètes sur les offres de stage sur
les droits des stagiaires sur les
organismes d'accueil euh ça permettrait
d'éviter sans doute des abus de mieux
informer les stagiaires ceux pour
lesquels les stages se sont mal déroulés
pourrai en parler décrire donc une telle
base de données nous paraît très utile
pour tout le monde les entreprises
d'accueil les stagiaires les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
qui pourrai suivre au fur à mesure des
années et des stages quand il y a des
milliers d'étudiants qui font des stages
il y a pas vraiment de regroupement qui
peut se faire ça contriburit à la
transparence des pratiques et ça me
paraît aller dans les souhaits du
gouvernement euh le 96 est simplement un
amendement de
repli si le gouvernement me disait qu'il
a pas les moyens matériels ou financiers
de mettre en place c'est de demander un
rapport encore qu'après euh
l'intervention de notre présidente
sur en commission sur tous les rapports
demandés et qui ne sont jamais remis je
préférerais ne pas avoir à faire à
présenter l'amendement de
repli monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces deux amendements
monsieur le Président c la création de
cette plateforme publique d'information
c'est une idée intéressante mais qui au
vu de la multiplicité des acteurs
concernés nous sommes très difficiles à
mettre en œuvre de plus n'est pas
véritablement une démarche de type Open
Data car il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
grande base de données publiques à ce
sujet sur lequ quel l'accès serait
restreint donc la Commission a souhaité
demander son avis au gouvernement quant
à l'amendement de repli de Madame
procacia la Commission est assez
défavorable à la multiplication des
demandes de rapport donc c'est un avis
défavorable madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement s'il vous plaît oui
monsieur le Président Madame la la
sénatrice en fait l'un de mes
prédécesseurs Laurent voquier he pour le
nommer avait mis en place une avait
tenté de mettre en place une
centralisation des données sur les
stages en en donnant la la gestion à
l'onicep c'était une une banque de de
données mais ça n'a pas marché tout
simplement parce que ces offres se font
au niveau des territoires et que leur
centralisation s'est avérit tout à fait
impossible donc là il s'agit pas d'
d'Open Data ou de
ou on est en dehors de ce sujet là on
est simplement sur la difficulté à
recueillir à un niveau central et à
colleationner à niveau central des
données qui sont des données
territorialisées donc il nous semble
beaucoup plus intéressant
de d'opérer ce travail à un niveau
territorialisé là on dispose des données
effectivement efficaces et sur l'Open
Data je vous dis au passage que le
secrétaire d'État à l'enseignement
supérieur à la recherche est le premier
ministère avoir mis en ligne des des
données donc vous y avez déjà accès dans
un certain nombre de secteurs mais en ce
qui concerne les stages vraiment il
dépend tellement du bassin d'emploi
local que leur centralisation s'est
avéré inefficace même si l'idée bonne
donc pour ces raisons je suis amené à
donner un avis
défavorable bien monsieur leenoir pour
explication de vote monsieur le
Président Madame la min mes chers
collègues je trouve que l'intention
inscrite dans l'amendement était
extrêmement intéressante alors la
réponse de Madame le Ministre me laisse
quand même un peu perplexe parce que
vous avez l'air de considérer que les
pouvoirs publicqus c'est les pouvoirs
public au niveau de l'état non les
pouvoirs publics ça peut-être également
au niveau régional au niveau despart au
niveau local ce sont les pouvoirs
publics organisés qui apportent un
certain nombre de services alors à
partir de là l'amendement peut très bien
cont tenu de l'argumentation que vous
avez défendu être adopté et concerné par
un fléchage que vous avez vous même
indiqué les pouvoirs publics
locaux
bien je mets au voix l'amendement 85 qui
est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement 85 n'est pas adopté le 86
même
vote NON je demande si c'est même vote
il a même vote donc il n'est pas
adopté après l'article 7 amendement qui
n'est pas
défendu puis un autre le 91 madame
procacia
euh le le 86 non non je il a été défendu
le 91
euh les il y a un problème dans les
dispositions enfin dans le texte de loi
tel que il nous a été transmis de
l'Assemblée nationale les nouvelles
dispositions devaient se s'appliquer aux
conventions on ne voudrait pas qu'elle
s'applique aux conventions de stage euh
qui ne sont signés et qui ont été signés
avant la publication des décrets
d'application c'est aussi après
l'article 7 l'article
90 va un peu dans ce sens en disant que
la loi ne rentrera en vigueur que pour
la rentrée universitaire 2014-2015 à
l'origine la loi devait s'appliquer au
mois d'avril et vous voulez que je
présente le
69 je présente le
69 le9 ne et bien il se il se content de
supprimer un mot de l'intittilé de la
proposition de loi puisque pour nous la
proposition de
loi tant à l'encadrement des stages et à
l'amélioration des stagiaires mais pas à
la au développement des stages puisque
ça va compliquer beaucoup les
choses bien je vous remercie chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur si vous
pouvez aussi nous donner les votre avis
sur les trois amendements oui monsieur
le président sur l'amendement 91 il est
logique que les dispositions de ce texte
qui nécessitent un décret d'application
ne seront pas applicables avant que
celui-ci soit publié c'est un principe
général et sur ce point cet amendement
est satisfait en revanche toutes les
dispositions de ce texte n'appelle pas
le décret la plupart sont d'application
directe et il faut pas retarder leur
mise en œuvre comme à chaque fois on
souhaite que les décrets soient plis le
plus rapidement possible sur le donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement 90 différit l'entrée en
vigur en vigueur je tiens à rassurer les
signataires de cet amendement le vote de
cette loi ne modifiera pas les
conventions de stage déjà signées elle
ne s'appliquera qu'X conventions signées
postérieurement à son entrée en vigueur
et pour certaines dispositions à la
publication des décrets nécessaires donc
le but n'est pas de porter atteinte aux
conventions légalement conclus et par
contre il contraire il est au contraire
nécessaire que cette proposition de loi
achève son examen parlementaire dans les
meilleurs délais pour qu'elle soit
applicable dès que possible quant à la
dernière le dernier le 69 euh j'ai mis
un avis la Commission a mis un avis de
de désaccord complet quoi du fait que le
supprimer la motion la motion
développement alors que l' voit bien
qu'il y a un développement tout à fait
important depuis quelques années des
stages donc c'est un avis défavorable
pour les
trois madame la ministre également votre
avis sur les trois amendements s'il vous
plaît oui même avis pour les mêmes
raisons bien donc je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 8 11 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté jour après l'article 7
l'amendement 90 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté et enfin le
69 même vote même vote il n'est pas
adopté non
plus alors
donc vote également sur
la alors je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
il a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
oui oui madame procacia déjà
oui d'abord je me félicite qu'on termine
le texte ce soir parce que à
avoir séquence permanent c'est vraiment
très désagréable et CIT comme je l'ai
dit à un moment à se demander si le
gouvernement avait envie que l'on vote
ou pas ce texte parce que vous l'avez
présenté comme étant un texte important
et c'était parsemé tout au long de
l'emploi du temps quand il y avait des
trous bon pour notre part le groupe UMP
estime que c'est un texte important de
toute façon les la loi sur les stages
les lois sur les stages c'est l'UMP et
les gouvernements précédents qui ont
lancé toutes les bases et le texte et
vous l'aviez bien dit d'ailleurs madame
la ministre dans votre intervention et
effectivement ce texte le complète et
mais complexifie en même temps des
dispositions qui existaient déjà et pour
lesquelles on aurait pu se contenter de
prendre des décrets qui n'étaient pas
pris et surtout on aurait pu si la
volonté du gouvernement était de faire
un texte c'est de faire un texte qui
sanctionne les entreprises euh qui ne
sont pas euh qui qui ne respectait pas
la réglementation actuelle des stages là
de toutes les auditions que nous avons
mené nous avons compris que les choses
allaient faire encore un peu plus peur
aux entreprises en particulier aux PME
qui sont pas euh armés pour ça et c'est
une des craintes du groupe UMP c'est que
effectivement l'offre de stage aille en
diminu
et non pas en
facilitant les les les offres je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure pour l'article 1 pour
ma part j'estime qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'avancé
j'apprécie que la Commission et queun
certain nombre de collègues sur les
bancs divers et vooté plus d'une dizaine
d'amendements pour ma part je
m'abstiendrai donc sur ce texte en
espérant en espérant que dans la CMP un
certain nombre des avancées du Sénat
demeure mais le groupe UMP dans son
ensemble est opposé à la plupart de ses
dispositions et donc le groupe
EMP pour sa part sauf individuellement
certains d'entre nous votera contre ce
texte bien madame fer pour explication
de vote merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
nous voici donc arrivé à l'essue de ces
débats j'allais dire aussi enfin et je
ne crois trahir le sentiment de personne
en disant que l'examen de ce texte a
semblé
interminable pourquoi pour la bonne et
simple raison qu'il s'est effectué dans
des conditions proprement déplorable
comment a-t-on pu je ne trouve pas
d'autres mots ce soir saucissonner mais
c'est vraiment le mot qui convient à ce
point cette proposition qu'on en juge
une discussion à peine entamée le 29
avril
poursuivi le 6 mai et c'est un miracle
si grâce à la bonne volonté de chacun
nous l'avons terminé aujourd'hui et
monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
nous a dit qu'il était encore prévu une
fenêtre mardi 27 mai nous y avons
échappé c'est un message très positif
envoyé aux jeunes vous en conviendrez
signe du grand cas que l'on fait de leur
sort et qui prouve à quel point on se
souci de leur insertion dans l'emploi
quand au fond notre appréciation n'est
guerre plus positive et elle peut être
résumé en une formule celle de notre
collègue Jean-Léon Dupont le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien oui bien sûr il faut un
cadre minimal au stage et cela nous
l'avons toujours défendu le groupe et la
famille politique auquel j'appartiens
ont fait partie des plus actifs et des
plus mobilisés pour mettre en place un
tel cadre je rappellerai que cela a été
fait à l'initiative de Jean-Louis borlot
alors ministre de l'emploi du travail et
de la cohésion sociale dans la loi du 31
mars 2006 pour l'égalité des chances
l'article 9 de cette loi légalisit la
convention de stage mettait en place une
gratification pour les stages longs et
limitait la durée maximale de ces stages
par la suite dans la loi ESR du 22
juillet 2013 madame la ministre que vous
connaissez parfaitement nous avons fait
adopter un amendement pour interdire que
les stages puisse servir à pourvoir un
emploi permanent dans l'administration
publique et les ass iation et pas
seulement dans les entreprises ce cadre
protège les stagiaires et c'est bien
normal mais le présent texte va bien
plus loin et bien trop loin il crée un
carcan rigide totalement
anti-économique en effet il établit des
contrates nouvelles dont l'un des plus
emblématiques est sans doute celle du
côat de stagiaire par rapport aux
effectif de l'entreprise et universalise
celle qui existait déjà conséquence ce
ce cadre nouveau est totalement inadapté
à certains secteurs d'activité et à
certains acteurs économiques exemple de
secteur d'activité celui de
l'agriculture et de l'enseignement
agricole pour lequel vous l'avez compris
je me suis engagé comment voulez-vous
que la règle de la gratification et de
la durée maximale des stages y soit
applicable pour autant doit-on arrêter
de former les jeunes le résultat risque
donc d'être totalement contre-productif
puisqu'il conduira les jeunes à ne plus
trouver de stage pour soi-disant mieux
les protéger on voit les privés de cette
voie d'insertion privilégié je dis
privilégié et j'ajoute aussi
incontournable mais je l'ai déjà
tellement répété puisque'aujourd'hui les
stages sont indispensables pour valider
nombre de formations le cadre mis en
place par le texte est aussi totalement
incompatible avec l'activité de certains
acteurs économiques tels que les PME et
les entreprises naissantes ces
entreprises ont besoin de stagiaire de
manière plus souple pour survivre
prospérer et donc créer de l'emploi
parce que le stagiaire d'aujourd'hui est
le salarié de demain c'est cela que l'on
semble oublier encore plus
fondamentalement la philosophie même de
ce texte est très problématique
puisqu'il tend à faire entrer le
stagiaire dans un statut de salariat
c'est très grave parce que c'est oublié
que le stagiaire est avant tout un jeune
en formation parce que c'est aussi aux
antipodes du choc de compétitivité et de
simplification que nous elon de nos vœux
et qui malgré tous les pactes de
responsabilité ne semble toujours pas
devoir se profiler nous avions déposé un
certain nombre d'amendements visant à
assouplir le texte ils nont
malheureusement pas été retenus dans ces
conditions madame la ministre vous
comprendrez que la très grande majorité
des membres du groupe uduc vote contre
le texte présent merci de votre
attention madame Génisson pour
explication de
vote
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues la construction de l'avenir
des jeunes et j'en suis persuader une
priorité politique que nous partageons
tous les jeunes vivent aujourd'hui dans
un environnement qui n'est pas toujours
facile à assumer une longue phase de
précarité le lot de beaucoup d'entre eux
et cela concerne aussi beaucoup de ceux
qui qui ont une formation c'est dans ce
contexte que les stages ont connu
néanmoins ces dernières années un
développement exponentiel pour de bonnes
raisons la professeur istion des études
la capacité des entrants sur le marché
du travail à être rapidement
opérationnel et intégré dans le monde du
travail mais aussi pour de mauvaises
raisons l'utilisation de jeunes souvent
diplômés est immédiatement exploitable
dans un contexte de fort chômage et de
difficultés économiques le sujet du
développement des stages du statut des
stagiaire occupe le législateur depuis
de nombreuses années ça a été dit par
les intervenants précédents je veux
rendre particulièrement hommage à notre
rapporteur qui depuis 2006 et au cours
de nos débats actuels a prouvé sa
compétence sa détermination son
engagement merci aussi à vous madame la
ministre vous qui avez été à l'écoute
des propositions émanant de nous tous et
nos débats ont été de grande qualité
même s'ils ont été longs avec ce nouveau
texte nous avons encore progressé nous
protégeons mieux les jeunes avec des
dispositions concernant la durée
concernant la durée des stages le
renforcement des missions des
établissements d'enseignement la
définition plus précise des tuteurs la
limitation du nombre de stagiaires par
enseignant et par entreprise la lutte
contre les abus de stage avec
intervention de l'inspection du travail
nous avons adopté deux amendements très
importants à l'initiative de notre
rapporteur Jean-Pierre gaefroy l'un pour
l'augmentation de 90 € de la
gratification minimale l'autre pour que
cette gratification soit obligatoire
après un mois de stage pour les
stagiaires de l'enseignement
supérieur contrairement à certains le
groupe socialiste ne pense pas que les
dispositions de ce texte vont arrir
l'offre de stage
nous soutenons que les entreprises les
collectivités les associations dans leur
grande majorité souhaitent participer à
la construction de l'avenir des jeunes
si la majorité des organismes les
accueille bien et même avec plaisir il
est important de définir des règles pour
éviter les dérives les jeunes dès lors
qu'ils sont respectés seront d'autant
plus motivés ce texte est un signal fort
pour l'intégration de qualité dans le
monde du travail permettez-moi d'évoquer
aussi la qualité de nos travaux
concertés sur le sujet des stagiaires
des Maison Familiale Rurale nous avons
tous évoqué ce sujet et merci au
gouvernement d'avoir trouvé d'avoir
trouvé le le bon décret qui permet de
d'intégrer de façon satisfaisante ces
stagiaires dans effectivement un lieu
d'enseignement qui est tout à fait
intéressant l'Assemblée nationale a
accompli une partie du travail sur
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
nous avons je le pense encore amélioré
le texte et le groupe socialiste votera
ce texte de nos débats très
constructif bien monsieur revet pour
explication de vote oui merci monsieur
le Président Madame le Ministre madame
procacia a indiqué tout à l'heure quelle
était la position de notre groupe et je
le partage fais partie de la très grande
majorité qui ne vont pas voter le texte
parce que je suis inquiet je suis inquet
des
conséquences de certaines dispositions
qui alourdissent les
procédure l'objectif l'obligation pour
des jeunes c'est de faire des stages or
pratiquement sur tous les
bancs nous avons dit que nous étions
souvent sollicités par des jeunes aux
abois qui ne trouvait pas de stage et
leur diplôme étai en
cause je crains très franchement que les
dispositions qui
alourdissent les condition
les reprises pour l'accueil de ces
jeunes ne fasse un recul d'un certain
nombre d'entre elles et que ce sera ce
soit au détriment des jeunes qui doivent
être notre
objectif je souhaite n nous trompions
mais je crains que ce soit le cas et
c'est pour ça que comme la majorité du
groupe je voterai contre ce
texte explication de vote oui monsieur
le Président Madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je veux tout d'abord
remercier notre rapporteur Jean-Pierre
gafroit parce que je trouve qu'il était
particulièrement attentif tout au long
des débats pendant la la Commission et
puis dans l'hémicycle et qu'il a été
fidèle à la proposition de loi qu'il
avait fait en 2006 c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on s'est pas mal retrouvé même si
on n' pas réussi à faire adhérer
l'ensemble de de l'hémicycle sur un
certain nombre de points donc je vais
commencer par les choses que nous
trouvons encore un peu trop frileuse ou
trop négative frileuse et trop négative
parce que y compris le candidat François
Hollande euh avait s'était avancé par
rapport à cet encadrement des stagiaires
et notamment avait promis une allocation
pour la jeunesse qui se fait attendre et
à mon avis qui va pas voir le le jour
malheureusement donc je pense qu'on
aurait pu faire preuve d'un un peu plus
d'audace pour aider à encadrer encore de
meilleure façon les stagiaires euh point
négatif je regrette qu'une partie de la
gauche est voté avec la droite un
amendement qui a supprimé l'alinéa 40
dans l'article 1er et qui est très grave
puisque je le lis le temps de présence
du stagiaire fixé par la convention de
stage ne peut excéder la durée légale
hebdomadaire de travail fixé donc par
l'article l31 21 100 du Code du travail
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait exploser les 35
cœur ouvrant la porte à la durée donc
d'un temps de travail incompatible avec
de mon point de vue et du point de vue
de mon groupe un statut d'élèves ou
d'étudiants digne du 21e siècle donc
j'espère que la CMP va revenir là-dessus
donc des points qui sont qui sont
effectivement négatif mais en même temps
et heureusement la loi et en tout cas
dans dans son esprit prend un certain
nombre de positions qui vont permettre
de réduire
considérablement les les abus que
pouvaient vivre les St
et nous nous nous nous réjouissons
particulièrement d'un encadrement par
rapport à ces à ces stagiaires notamment
dans l'université avec une limitation du
nombre d'étudiants ce qui est tout à
fait positif et donc un encadrement qui
va être bien meilleur d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue qualité nous nous
réjouissons également qu'un certain
nombre de nos amendements qui allaient
dans le sens de la philosophie donc de
de de cette loi et pu être adopté par
exemple en étendant à l'ensemble des
stagiaires même ceux ne bénéficiant pas
de gratification l'accès à la
restauration scolaire au titre
restaurant et à la prise en charge des
titres de transport de même en
permettant aux stagiaires dans
l'impossibilité de poursuivre leur stage
d'avoir une autre possibilité de de
validation offert par l'établissement
d'accueil ou le réconfort donc je crois
que tout ça c'est intéressant c'est
positif et je regrette que dans cet
hémicycle on a trop voulu faire peur en
tout cas dans une partie de l'hémicycle
en disant que en adoptant ces mesure
positive dans l'intérêt des stagiaires
et bien nous allions mettre en péril
l'avenir des entreprises je ne crois pas
du tout je crois qu'au contraire ça va
permettre de modifier la qualité aider à
la qualité des stage et donc apporter
plus de sécurité pour les futurs
salariés s'ils sont ils sont embauchés
c'est dans ce sens donc nous trouvons
important de voter cette proposition de
loi et je vous dis en espérant vraiment
que lors de la CMP et bien les les
désagrements qui ont pu être votés
peut-être par fatigue lassitude ou par
manque de réflexion puisse être revu en
tout cas c'est ce que je pense bon je
provoque peut-être un peu à cette
heure-elà parce que je crois que tout le
monde a voté en son âme et conscience
mais ça vous permet comme ça de montrer
que vous êtes toutes et tous attentif je
vous
remercie bien monsieur des
cessar
à mon avis conserv
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre fallait réglementer on est tous
d'accord avec le constat qu'il y a des
abus il a des abus bien sûr ce sont les
abus de patron indélicat de chef
d'entreprise qui trouvve une main
d'œuvre au Bon Marché motivé mais
parfois aussi des associations
des entreprises en difficulté qui bon
prennent un stagiaire pour parce queil y
a pas les moyens de faire autrement et
également ça s'appuie ces abus sur la
détresse des jeunes qui trouvent pas de
premier emploi et qui disent faut mieux
que je fasse un stage plutôt que rien
faire et le stage me permettra de
rentrer dans l'entreprise et cela un an
2 ans et 3 ans donc il fallait
réglementer et ce n'était pas facile
tant les situations
différente donc nous le groupe
écologiste on est s situé dans la
logique présentée par la proposition de
loi soutenue par le gouvernement d'une
réforme cohérente d'un statut qui serait
le même pour chaque stagiaire en cela on
aurait pu et je comprends la logique
aussi défendue par l'UMP et l'UDI de
faire par secteur ça aurait été plus
long là certainement qu'on aurait
discuté plus longtemps
que peut-être que ça aurait été
davantage adapté en tout cas là il y a
une stratégie par par rapport à cette
proposition de loi qui était de dire il
y a une cohérence globale et c'est le
même statut pour l'ensemble des
stagiaires cela sera le garde-fou contre
les abus donc nous sommes situés dans la
stratégie de la proposition de loi qui a
été respecté globalement et donc nous
voterons ce texte alors une petite
remarque générale c'est
que il fallait maintenir le mot
développement madame procacia dans le
titre de la proposition de loi je je
pense que les jeunes ont besoin de
s'investir dans entreprise le fait que
pour un certain nombre de de de jeunes
issus de milieu défavorisés le fait de
se sentir utile le fait de se coltiner à
la réalité de ne pas être en train
simplement d'écouter dans une classe de
25 ou 30 élèves le professeur pendant 6
ou 7 he dans la journée c'est quelque
chose de très important il faut
absolument développer la pratique et
encore une dernière
remarque
madame F vous avez dit quel est
l'intérêt pour une entreprise
d'accueillir je le saisil y a un intérêt
pour une entreprise et pour les tuteurs
c'est de se sentir utile c'est de
transmettre un savoir effectivement
chacun est valorisé dans l'échange dans
le fait que les connaiss reste pas
inutile mais que on sent un jeune qui
est prêt à s'approprier
qui se se se motive et comment apprend
et c'est effectivement très enrichissant
à la fois pour le jeune et le formateur
donc je crois que nous défendons tous
l'idée qu'il y ait plus de formation
nous considérons et c'est pour ça que
nous avons été contre certains
amendements qui tendaient à rapprocher
le statut du stagiaire du statut du
statut de salarié nous considérons
qu'aujourd'hui le stage fait partie de
la formation il en sera peut-être pas de
même dans quelques années si la
situation économique ne s'améliore pas
et on pourra à ce niveau-là être très
inquiet mais nous
parionons sur le fait que il y aura une
stabilité que j'espère que on pourra
s'en sortir économiquement autrement
c'est quand même tout le système social
qu'il faudra revoir en tout cas nous
avons nous sommes restés dans l'idée que
le stage est une période de formation
qu'il fallait réglementer contre les
abus le texte cette proposition de loi
correspond à cet objectif correspond à
cette stratégie et le groupe écologiste
votera donc cette proposition de
loi Monsieur L noir pour explication de
vote oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre nous avons légiférer sur un
texte qui est parti d'un constat que
nous partagions à savoir qu'il y avait
des abus concernant les les stages
effectués dans le cadre de
l'enseignement
supérieur la preuve qu'on était sur
cette ligne là c'est que c'est Madame
chorazo ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui représente le
gouvernement on aurait apprécié d'avoir
plus longtemps le ministre en charge des
affaires sociales et du travail on
aurait pu voir également la présence du
ministre en charge de l'éducation
nationale donc ça voulait bien dire que
le texte visait comme nous l'avions
compris un certain nombre d'abut
constatés dans le cadre de
l'enseignement supérieur
soit à quoi avons-nous assister
finalement à un grand débat et au vote
d'un certain nombre de dispositions qui
reparlait d'une façon parfois un peu
pellmelle des stages en entreprise de
l'apprentissage au point que parfois on
se demandait de quoi on
parlait alors si effectivement j'en ai
parlé et j'en parle encore maintenant
c'est bien pour montrer qu'il fallait
distinguer les stages
des statuts
d'apprentis alors on en est arrivé un
texte qui
malheureusement je ne veux pas préjuger
le résultat risque d'aller à l'encontre
des jeunes dont nous avons beaucoup
parlé pendant ces débats qui cherchent
des stages pour valider une formation et
qui faut de stage ne peuvent pas obtenir
de poursuivre jusqu'à son terme leur
cursus
d'étude cette complexification fait
qu'effectivement on peut s'interroger
sur les effets parvers du texte qui aura
été délibéré et nous parlons madame la
Présidente non madame Cohen non pas
tellement des entreprises mais nous
parlons bien de l'avenir des stagiaires
c'est bien de qu'il s'agit et c'est bien
eux que nous pensions quand nous avions
à plusieurs reprises les uns et les
autres sur différents bancs évoqué la
présence danss permanences de jeunes qui
désespéré nous demand notre aide pour
avoir accès à un
stage alors mon premier mouvement de
même que celui de mes amis était de
voter contre pour autant
il y a eu un certain nombre d'avancé que
je ne me connais pas dû d'abord à
l'écoute de madame la ministre je le
reconnais vous avez écouté y compris
l'opposition lorsque nous avons évoqué
certains sujets etme nous avons eu
l'impression que dans les heures qui
avaient suivi notre séance de la semaine
dernière un certain nombre de démarches
avaient été accomplies qui vous
permettaient de vous rapprocher de
d'organisme de formation dont nous vous
parlions c'est du également l'attitude
de Monsieur rapporteur certains pourront
évidemment évoquer la solidarité
territoriale qui nous unit en
BasseNormandie elle n'est pas suffisante
pour dire que j'ai apprécié la façon
dont notre rapporteur a conduit la
mission qui lui a été confiée il y a eu
surtout un certain nombre d'avancées
dont une à laquelle je tenais
particulièrement et qui concernait les
Maisons Familiales Rurales moi je prends
acte qui a eu des avancées nous y avons
les uns et les autres contribué les mais
en famill male rural nous ont fait
savoir qu'elles avaient beaucoup
apprécié la façon dont les choses
s'étaient déroulées et la façon dont
nous avions finalement conclu le débat
c'est la raison pour laquelle sans avoir
l'idée que je me désolidarise de qui que
ce soit je m'abstiendrai sur le vote de
ce
texte bien
je vais donc mettre aux
voix
et comment
oui et bien je je viens de voir mais je
ne vous avez pas donc excusez-moi mais
vous pouvez donc intervenir je vous en
prie madame Laborde excusez-moi monsieur
le Président de ma spontanéité mais il
me semblait que justement je voilà merci
donc monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre vu les efforts du gouvernement
pour accepter un certain nombre
d'amendements par exemple en effet
concernant les Maisons familiales
rurales ou sur certains avantages tel
lestickets restaurant ou titre de
transport pour tous les stagiaires et
enfin le dernier visant à inciter
l'embauche des jeunes de moins de 26 ans
qui passeraient du statut de stagiaire à
celui de salarié en CDI tous les membres
du RDSE voteront cette proposition de
loi madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur merci d'avoir permis
l'évolution du statut des stagiaires qui
parfois était utilisé selon la vilain
expression entendue ce soir je me
permettrai d'insister sur l'amendement
115 qui a été très discuté et ce serait
dommage qu'il disparaisse en commission
mixte paritaire ma chè collègue je nous
pensons le contraire de ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure et je peux vous
confirmer que l'amendement de Monsieur
Barbier n'est pas le fruit de la fatigue
mais bien celui de la réflexion je vous
remercie
bien
donc cette fois je vais donc céder au
vote j'ai été d'ailleurs saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par les
groupes UMP et socialiste sur l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi il doit donc
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
minutes quelques instants
même
bien le scrutin est
ouvert
jà
à vousz pas
question
personne ne demande à voter donc le le
scrutin est clos et j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin est
qu'
rés du scrutin numéro 183 sur l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrage exprimé
331 pour l'adoption 181 contre
150 le Sénat a adopté la proposition de
loi tendant au développement à
l'encadrement des stages et à
l'amélioration du statut des
stagiaires voilà vous avez donc pu
suivre l'examen de cette proposition de
loi tendant à améliorer le statut et les
droits des stagiaires un texte qui a été
voté hier soir par le Sénat tout de
suite la suite de nos programmes sur
publ
Sénat